what do you think is the best film of
all time maybe top uh top three yeah
maybe The Godfather Godfather okay The
Godfather is is definitely up there
Francis Coppola is one of my heroes have
you met him I have met him yes yes yes I
I was very very lucky we were very lucky
uh to work with him on his new film at
gallopolis which is coming out I hope in
2024 and think about the cities of the
future in in the context of new
materials and
the unity between nature and culture
Godfather is definitely up there
um 2001 is up there
I would watch that film again and again
and again
it's incredible the last scene in
Odyssey 2001 that's
um just watch the last scene of 2001
then listen to it and then sort of and
then go to the garden and that's pretty
much you know the end in the beginning
but that scene that last scene from 2001
is everything
it says so much with so little and it
leaves
it it's sort of the embodiment I believe
of
ambivalence and
um there's opportunity to believe in the
beginning of humankind the end of
humankind the planet child star or star
child of the future
um was there a death was there an
reincarnation
um you know that final scene to me is
something that I go back to and and
study and every time there is a
different reading of that scene that
inspires me so that that scene just and
then the first scene in The Godfather
still one of the best scenes of all
times sort of a portrait of America the
ideals and values that I brought from
Italy and a family of loyalty of uh yes
of values of how how different values
are constructed yes
loyalty and and the human spirit and how
Coppola celebrates the human Spirit
through the most sinful gestures in
language and acting and I think in in
Kubrick you see this highly curated and
controlled and manicured
um vision of of creating a film and with
with Francis it's
it's like an Italian Feast it's like
anything anything can happen at any
moment in time
and just being on the set with him is
um is an experience I'll take with me to
my grave it's it's very very very
special and he said music is also part
of that of creating a feeling in the
movies yeah actually the The Godfather
um
That Tune that makes me like emotional
every time on some weird level yeah it's
one of these Tunes I'm sure that has
you know we played two
[Music]
to a Jasmine you'll get the best scent
of all time so I think like there's but
I think with that particular tune I
learned staccato
something very very happy and joyous
and then made into this stretched in
time and became kind of the refrain of
Nostalgia and Melancholy and loyalty and
all of these values that ride on top of
this one single tune
you can play in all kinds of different
ways I've I've played on guitar in all
kinds of different ways and I think in
Godfather 3 the sun plays it on guitar
to the father
I think this happens in movies
but sometimes a melody and that's a
simple Melody you can just like
and the Strauss melody in 2001 yep and
when you juxtapose
this
um this Melodies with
the scene you get this again hole that's
bigger than some of its parts where you
get this moment
that is I think
like these are the moments I would send
you know with the next Voyager to outer
space I definitely sent the Godfather in
in 2001 would definitely be beyond that
um golden record